et regardez de qu'on se parle ça c'est
le nouveau film i 9 4 j padrines me 9,5
g mais avec un remy nice 4g vous avez un
tarif canon oui je vous l'annoncé en
version 6 g garde ram 128 g à de
stockage il à 279 90 g tous là il
doutait bien que j'ai pas tout appris
par coeur les tarifs c'est pas mon truc
mais ça c'est intéressant pourquoi c'est
intéressant parce que c'est un
smartphone qui est 4g serre est ce que
vous avez besoin de la 5g il ya plein de
personnes qui ne veulent pas de 5 g et
qui veut juste un bon prix un smartphone
suffisamment spéc et avec un plein de
choses à l'intérieur donc ça ça coûte
279,99 je tape dessus comme ça mais il
ne crée rien parce que la boîte est
résistante peut même la jetez donc tout
va bien qu'aujourd'hui une vidéo qui
réalise en partenariat des crimes
mirilli m'a dit tiens monsieur re est ce
que tu ne voudrais pas découvrir notre
nouveau smartphone 4g pas 5g tout en
sachant que ya son grand frère 5 g qui
sort également un prix un peu plus élevé
c'est un peu différent donc aujourd'hui
on va se regarder ce smartphone on va
regarder s'il est intéressant et surtout
très grosse surprise je vous ai déjà
parlé de l'ennemi il ya des écouteurs il
ya plein de trucs mais même aspirateur
oui font plein de choses ils ont ça
c'est une tablette elle s'appelle la pad
min voyez ces écrits si noir sur blanc
tablette de rim me on va en parler très
très rapidement aujourd'hui débute cette
part du smartphone on y va bingo
[Musique]
j'aime bien quand les marques font des
promesses intéressante sur ce smartphone
ya plein de jolies promesses
intéressantes ici on a une triple caméra
avec surtout un capteur principal c'est
vraiment lui qui va nous intéresser le
capteur principal signé samsung 100 8
mégapixels sur un smartphone à un tout
petit peu moins de 280 euros ça c'est
intéressant un capteur de 100 8
mégapixels ok pourquoi pas et ce
smartphone il fait plein de jolies
promesses l'écran on va le regarder en
quelques instants il ya quoi le
processeur également puis à très très
grosse batterie vous savez je pas si
vous le savez sur les smartphones dans
cette gamme de prix les constructeurs il
vous mettre des grosses batteries pour
jouer l'autonomie parce que c'est un des
points forts je pense qu'en fait c'est
ce qui la route le moins cher est ici
rnb n'a pas non plus été égoïste avec
une très grosse batterie première chance
on commence par l'ouvrir
[Musique]
faut les secouer un peu alors comme
d'hab on a le même petit message et
welcome to win me fahmi lit ça ça me
convient bien qu'est ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur de ça on va retrouver de
quoi on va le tiroir de cartes sim on va
avoir un petit guide de démarrage on va
avoir des informations hockey en suisse
qu'est ce que j'ai le smartphone qui est
là dans ce petit pochette sorte à
chaussettes qui est je me suis coupé les
ont trop cool quoi voilà assez marrant
ces deux couleurs corsa rappelle
légèrement leurs jeunes mais pas
vraiment il ya des reflets ya un espèce
d'effet vague j'ai l'impression que le
smartphone il et ondulé en fait c'est
très marrant cet effet visuel prise jack
hockey d'en conserver une prière car
c'est plutôt pas mal le haut parleur
tiroirs de cartes sim ok d'ailleurs fait
de voir tout de suite là on va checker
ça qu'est-ce qui nous ont mis en carte
sim ici là on en a deux on a quoi on a
donc double tiroirs de carte sim plus
carte microsd pour augmenter à la
mémoire de son smartphone ça c'est pas
mal on attend que jamais besoin dans le
bon sens parce que sinon je vais tout
casser ça c'est quand même dommage dans
la chaufferie que c'est ensuite à
l'intérieur bombe à un câble pour
recharger votre en doute et alors ça
c'est bob dechert intéressant on est
encore bien là dessus 33 watts et le
maximum ok donc ça c'est pas mal bon bah
c'est sommaire mais ça fonctionne et
puis on va lui mais le smartphone pas
mal ce look quand même moi j'aime bien
ce dollars garder ses reflets là qu'on
va voir je trouve que c'est plutôt bien
vu de la part de rim ni ça et ça
fonctionne le petit module photo cl est
sympa on espère un dos en plastique on
s'en doutera mais je trouve que
globalement la prise en main est assez
bonne le ratio est correct c'est un
smartphone attention on n'a pas inventé
l'eau chaude ni la poudre ici mais ce
qu'il fait il le fait plutôt pas mal le
design élégant sympathique donc ça déjà
c'est un très bon point ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'à 281 balle on a
des specs qui sont plutôt cool et qui
tiennent vraiment la route pourvoir
compter sur un smartphone dont l'entrée
milieu de gamme c'est toujours un peu ce
qu'on comme ça qu'on va venir définir sa
alors regarder des gens d'un capteur
d'empreintes digitales sous l'écran ça
déverrouille rapidement ça c'est quand
même plutôt pas mal truc qui est cool
ici c'est que vous avez un écran avec un
taux de rafraîchissement regardez c'est
du 90e alors l'écran est grand on a
quand même eu la jarre bordure en bas
une fois de plus dans cette gamme de
prix on va pas chipoter non plus on
vient d'en affichage et luminosité et
vous allez retrouver fréquence
d'actualisation de l'écran il est celle
est automatiquement parce qu'en fait il
monte à 90 heures salle auront pu
pousser si et ça mais on s'en fiche
voulait laisser comme ça c'est quand
même bien moi je trouve d'avoir un taux
de rafraîchissement 90 hier sur un
smartphone a une fois de plus de 280
balle donc ça c'est bien parce que on va
pas se mentir c'est quoi les usages au
niveau des smartphones regardait des
films des séries faire des jeux alors
attention ici vous avez un smartphone
qui coule mais on va pas aller faire
tourner un fort tenaille dans la plus
haute confie on va se calmer on est sur
un smartphone qui coûte quand même 291
je le dis parce que
c'est important vraiment de très très
bien re situer ce smartphone il est
plutôt bien positionné dans pas mal de
choses mais il excelle pas dans tout
vous avez un processeur qualcomm
snapdragon 680 c'est un processeur qui
4g uniquement mais une fois de plus remy
a dû arbitrer un choix soit ils vous
mettait un processeur un peu plus
puissants directement ici n'est
peut-être que vous auriez pas vu un
écran oled est ce qu on veut ici c'est
un écran oled amoled d'ailleurs parce
que sa manière à maximiser l'expérience
que vous allez venir regarder des films
des séries lorsque vous allez jouer à
des jeux ça sera mieux que un écran lcd
bas donc il ya eu des choix il ya eu des
coupes à faire là dedans en termes de
budget et on a un écran oled ça c'est
cool autre truc qui est cool et je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est la batterie
ici de 5000 militaires alors on la voit
pas mais doit être probablement par ici
ça permet d'avoir une autonomie qui va
vous emmener jusqu'à un jour et demi
deux jours ça dépend une fois de plus de
aux usages alors là on est sur une
version avec 6 giga de ram mais moi ce
que j'aime bien ce qu'ils viennent faire
un truc que font beaucoup de
constructeurs aujourd'hui ses phares de
la ram dynamique vous avez aussi giga de
ram et dès lors que vous avez de la
place pour le stockage on vient taper
dans la rome c'est hier dans le stockage
pour vous permettre d'avoir un peu plus
de ram et on peut monter jusqu'à 13
juillet drame de façon un peu dynamique
alors c'est pas réellement du 13 10 gars
drame en soyons soyons clair ça
permettra pas vraiment de gagner
beaucoup de fluidité faire tourner des
jeux plus puissant ça va venir améliorer
un peu l'expérience en terme de
navigation et c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal autre truc qui est intéressant
ce smartphone c'est que je trouve quand
même assez fin et souvent dans cette
gamme de prix dès qu'on avait un
smartphone
et à 280 euros je vous remets pris une
fois liste eh bien on avait des
smartphones un peu épais et ici il ya un
vrai parti pris qui a été fait au niveau
du design avec un smartphone qui en plus
d'être mignon niveau du dos est quand
même assez fin donc ça c'est cool last
but not least on va se la faire comme ça
comme je vous le disais vous êtes notre
capteur ici qui vous permet en plus de
l'utiliser de capteur de fréquence
cardiaque si vous en avez besoin regard
des résultats au niveau des photos hop
là on vient se rapprocher un peu c'est
plutôt bien dans l'ensemble on est sans
le capteur sont 8 mégapixels le fameux
capteurs sont 8 mégapixels de samsung ça
veut dire quoi alors ça va permettre
plus en chose ne va pas forcément avoir
des photos native orsan 8 mégapixels on
n'a pas réellement besoin mais grâce à
une technologie où on vient regrouper
différents pic saint loup à dire capter
un peu plus de lumière qui permettra de
chauffer un peu plus de détails par ils
font ça en interne un port lan petit
soft pour vous sortir des photos de
meilleure qualité est globalement c'est
pas mal alors attention je le dis je
leur à rabat je le répète on est à 280
euros donc il faut pas qu'on ait les
mêmes exigences qu'un smartphone à 400
500 600 milles banni de son bal 3000
euros cinquante mille euros on reste un
smartphone à un prix raisonnable donc ce
qu'on attend de ce smartphone c'est
d'avoir des photos de bonne qualité
d'avoir de bons souvenirs et c'est ce
qu'on va avoir ici vous reconnaîtrez
peut-être ici on les place de la
bastille je trouve qu'un truc
intéressant au niveau du hdr c'est qu'on
a quand même pas un ciel qui est cramé
l'album gestion globale de la lumière
dans un smartphone ans cette gamme de
prix une fois de plus qu'il fonctionnera
l'ultra grand temps de regarder la
colorimétrie est quand même différente
alors je vous le conseille vraiment
d'utiliser ultra grand-angle en plus si
vraiment ça passe pas dans le cadre des
fois vaut mieux ce recul un petit peu
pour avoir de meilleures photos avec
votre capteur principal ultra grand
angle on peut mais on va privilégier le
fait d'avoir un capteur de 5 mégapixels
pour sortir de meilleures choses très
honnêtement on peut bien se rapprocher
regardez là je n'avais pas montré mais
vous pouvez venir vous mais là en un
vous pouvez monter ensuite vous appuyer
là vous passez en x 3 directement on
peut monter en force un quai jusqu'au x
10 voyez comme ça et jeu sont claires
hop là à là je reviens ici lâchement
fois 3g déjà du bruit c'est normal x 5
davantage et leur fournissent n'en
parlons pas donc on va pas venir nous
mais on va axer notre capteur principal
ça c'est quand même plutôt cool j'ai une
bonne restitution je trouve de la
lumière alors c'est un poil sursaturé
mais c'est quand même plutôt sympa et
assez intéressant à venir regarder il
faut dire aussi qu'il fait beau
aujourd'hui à paris donc ça c'est cool
up photo et si la place de la bastille
j'ai un peu de nuages et fument
globalement ça va pas trop mal bonne
gestion de la lumière bonne gestion des
couleurs c'est très correct honnêtement
pour 281 gros là c'est pareil j'ai
vraiment voulu venir voir par rapport au
ciel ça me ressort très bien les nuages
voyez alors c'est un poil plus foncée
ici ça pourrait être un peu plus
éclairés mais globalement c'est trois
fois rien et une fois de plus
c'est un peu relou avec ça mais ça prend
alors si tu es ça fonctionne bien
l'appareil ici sur l'opéra bastille ça
fonctionne regardez tous les voyages et
le faire un petit tour de la place de la
bastille là c'est pareil ça très sympa
on a bien regardé les nuages c'est très
joli avec le ciel on voit bien ici ça ça
fonctionne les gens devant également
coucou à vous la caméra de cette fille
elle s'en sort pas trop mal c'est une 16
mégapixels ça permettra de faire
quelques souvenirs et moi ce que je vous
conseille honnêtement dans ce genre de
cas c'est vous prenez votre smartphone
vous le retourner et vous utilisez vos
boutons là et hop vous prenez votre
photo voyez comme ça vous avez une photo
qui fonctionnera avec une bien meilleure
qualité que si vous utilisiez à la
caméra de cette science est une petite
astuce et pour moi c'est cadeau mais
voyez sort quand même des choses qui
seront beaucoup plus sympas et vous
aurez une meilleure qualité voilà après
si ça vous va pas la caméra c'est le
fils a été le boulot aussi de toute
façon dans cette gamme de prix c'est
toujours une question de compromis un
constructeur peut pas tout vous mettre
une fois qu'en fait le choix qu'a fait
readme ici c'est de vous proposer un
smartphone abordable à 280 euros alors
attention parce que les offres de
lancement donc je vous mets tous les
liens en bas dans la description à
l'extérieur cliquer parce qu'il va y
avoir des choses intéressantes à des
prix plus bas donc c'est plutôt cool
mais ils ont voulu avoir un smartphone
équilibrée avec de très belles spec à
280 euros c'est la première fois qu'on a
un capteur de 8 mégapixels sur un
smartphone dans cette gamme de prix là
on a une très grosse batterie pour
l'autonomie on a un écran amoled vous
savez l'intérêt du amoled versus le lcd
c'est qu'en fait tous les pixels qui
vont être noir sont des pixels qui sont
éteints donc sa vraie noir ne paiera sa
le contraste infini même si le contraste
infini n'existe pas mais c'est juste en
fait que commencer et 1c noir c'est noir
avril ont nié peut pas se mentir ici
donc c'est tout l'intérêt en fait
d'avoir un smartphone qui va être
intéressant pour le visionnage qui va
vous offrir une bonne qualité
d'affichage avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 ans et apporter
de la fluidité à soutenir scrollé
lorsque vous allez venir jouer une fois
de plus un processeur qui sera
suffisamment performant même s'il en
sera pas des caisses qui fera le taf ici
on fait le choix de faire l'impasse sur
la 5g mais surtout on voit gros focus
écran divertissements photos photos
attention on fait des choix pas sur un
ultra grand-angle pas de télé objectifs
mais uniquement sur un capteur principal
qui fera le taf et qu'il le fera bien
tout en sachant que rémy s'est dit
jamais pourquoi s'arrêter là ça n'aurait
aucun sens donc on sort un smartphone
qui est effectivement kg ça c'est le
premier mais on sort également un
smartphone 5g en gris 9,5 g et c'est là
où tout ce que je vous ai dit prend
vraiment son sens où on voit les
compromis parce que pour avoir un
smartphone celui-là en 5 g il faut
remonter au niveau du processeur il faut
changer le 681 fonctionnera plus haut à
gauche sur le 695 5 juin qui va
forcément coûter plus cher et donc des
choix à faire on l'a donc plus un écran
amoled on a un écran lcd mais pour venir
vous récompenser vous faire plaisir si
vous voulez vraiment de la 5g ils ont
pas mis un taux de rafraîchissement de
90 ans et sont montés jusqu'à 120 hertz
pourquoi pas en garde ici par contre la
grosse batterie de 5000 billets en paire
eur et on est plus sûr sans 8 mégapixels
au niveau du capteur mais sur un 50 méga
pixels de la recharge rapide 18 watts
une caméra cette fille de 16 mégapixels
on va jusqu'à 16 gigaoctets de rendre
dynamique parce qu'on farissi deux de
plus bas on part de 4 en à une version 4
64 kg à 2 159 99 file vers sur 428 qui à
279 99 ça veut dire qu'en fait vous
allez avoir le même prix entre votre
ennemi 9,4 jérémy 9,5 g sauf que là
qu'on fixera pas exactement la même et
vous avez également 128 ce lieu de
stockage en retrait honnêtement moi ce
que je vous conseille si c'est de venir
prendre le smartphone en 4g pas à venir
prendre le smartphone en 5 g il est bien
mais voyez j'imagine que qualcomm leur
vend un peu plus cher quand même le sens
dragonne 195 vertu de sa dragonne 680
donc il a fallu opérer quelques choix
stratégique pour que le smartphone reste
à un tarif intéressant et pas que tout
de suite ça s'envole celui là alors vous
me direz on voit pas qui marque et qui
agit au sein de ge et le 4g c'est le
meilleur compromis c'est la meilleure
offre et comme je vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure il ya aussi une tablette on
revient très rapidement ça c'est plutôt
intéressant voyez pas ce qu'on voit que
l'écosystème augmentée vous aussi du
côté de jérémy donc on est une petite
tablette c'est plutôt sympa c'est
premium le dos à regarder on a quoi on a
ici une petite caméra d' c'est pas du 80
cédé 8 mégapixels alors surtout cette
tablette le tarif et l'hyper canonge
dénoter là on a une version 3 giga de
ram 32 gb de stockage à 179 euros 90 moi
ce que je vous recommande c'est la
version 64 géant du stockage à 199 90
pour pas vous retrouver bloqué par ce
qui arrivera un moment 32 go de stockage
pour moi c'est largement pas assez donc
on conseille cet habitat coûte 200 euros
pour avoir tout cas intéressant et après
on peut avoir une version également 4g
si vous le souhaitez ça sera du 404 ses
229 l'euro 90 secondes la petite
tablette coûte cher et demi c'est une
nouveauté c'est intéressant voyez readme
ça rime avec compromis alors je sais le
jeune loup est un peu facile mais je
voulais faire ça me fait plaisir c'est
cadeau c'est pour moi qu'est ce que j'en
dis moi de tous âges ont dit que au
final on apprend les smartphones j'en
dis que c'est marrant quand même hein
c'est une marque qui se développe de
plus en plus j'en parle
coup il ya des produits qui sont
intéressants alléchant à des tarifs
plutôt cadres ont donc ça fonctionnera
ce smartphone là il est bien ce qui vous
voulez de la cage et je vous le dis je
vous le rabâche 280 euros ça colle plus
tellement que j'ai collé par tout ce
truc là pour moi c'est le smartphone du
compromis s'il vole un smartphone sympa
qui se tient bien qu'elle la gueule vous
pouvez y aller et c'est un smartphone
qui est disponible en noir blanc et gold
en plus l'expérience read me why et cool
vous avez votre tiroir d'application on
a une bonne lisibilité sur les
applications clés code couleur sur le
côté l'espagne c'est cool a vous de me
dire vous ce que vous en pensez ce
smartphone à 280 euros est ce que ça
vous intéresse une fois de plus je vous
dis tout de suite 280 euros mais
attention souvent il ya des hommes donc
cliquer sur le lien en bas dans la
description pour venir découvrir ses
différentes offres et puis s'il vous
intéresse pourquoi pas bien vous faire
plaisir vous faire un cadeau à un ami
mais mis un copain cousin c'est
important de se faire des cadeaux dans
la vie on se fait passer de cadeaux dans
la vie voilà donc il faut se faire dès
qu'il fait beau des cadeaux faites vous
plaisir il pas ce que vous en pensez
mais je vous embrasse on se retrouve
très vite en continu à paris bien
évidemment de smartphones continuent à
se balader il ya plein de choses il ya
des voyages je vous emmène on va aller
s'évader et ça c'est bien parce qu'on
sait pas à s'évader pendant ces deux
dernières années donc là on retourne
s'évader et ça me fait tellement plaisir
vous emmener avec moi nous évader et
vaduz où c'est parti et va devant nous
en faisant des zooms voilà comme ça
allez bisous à bientôt
[Musique]